let's continue agl galloper okay so
1d4 we've been playing the queen's gamma
declined
okay so e4 is the blackmart dammer
gambit
you will um thank you on micro for the
prime you will see this at
you know the beginner level you'll even
occasionally see this at a high level
and the best um
the best way to respond to the black
martial is to take this pawn
[Music]
he's probably gonna probably going to go
f3 that's
okay nice c3 so
um let me remember so now we go knight
f6 we defend the pawn he's going to go
f3
he's probably going to go f3
all right i guess he doesn't really know
how to continue the point of the black
martimer is kind of a smith mora
on the opposite side of the board right
if you've seen the smith more in the
situation yeah he does go after me
so let me try to remember something guys
give me a second please
yeah so in the name of playing very
solidly
taking the pawn on f3 is not the best it
is the best move from a computer
perspective white does
not have enough compensation for the
pawn period
okay but very often when you want to
disarm a gambit
you want to do something that's in the
middle right you want to give away the
pawn
but in return get something resembling a
development advantage
so let's forget about this bond for a
second we don't we don't need to do
anything with it
what development move can you guys offer
so there's bishop f5 and i'll explain
why that's not not as good as it looks
afterward
but the move that i propose is knight c6
it actually does counter attack the pawn
white has the move d5 here which
would force this knight to move and
would slide into the e5 square
which is a knight up okay he goes bishop
f4 so he's insisting
on sacrificing the pawn
and that is not a good move it it allows
us now to take the pawn on d4
and there's no reason not to take the
spawn right he's just his center has
collapsed
he's giving up way too many pawns here
right so we're being very flexible in
our thinking process right knight b5
okay
so he's trying to be intimidating like
he's making moves that may look a little
bit scary
the calculation allows you to take the
staying out of moves like these all the
time
okay so the first question the obvious
question is
can we take the night is there any
reason not to take the night thank you
great broken chair
the only reason that i would even think
about it is well he can take the queen
and deprive us of castling rights but
again he's down two pawns
he's trading a lot of pieces and just
because our king is on d it doesn't mean
we're going to get checkmated
so we're going to take on b5 and maybe
he's attracted to the concept of taking
with check
nope he takes the queen and he
is going to take that now maybe he'll
castle yeah i was about to say that
now this is a common mistake right he
thinks he's going to make an in-between
move
and then you know leisurely take the
knight but he's missed
that we can simultaneously move this
knight and defend against the check at
the same time
that is basically the game we're up two
pawns now
and uh and a piece bishop okay so he
played anymore but
while i cannot take this bishop this
move
loses any of its use okay so now we need
to focus as we always do
on developing our pieces and not
forgetting about our development even
though it's an endgame
let me just play bishop d7 here
offering the trade of bishops again if
if there is a key if there's a clear
path to simplification
when you're up you know when you're up
material then you should go
go forward king takes d7 then we're
going to play e6 and bishop b7
and again you shouldn't overthink that
the technique here actually now let's
take on f3 now that he's moved his
knight away from g1
you know a very classy move here would
be what what would be sort of the most
clinical move
so i would propose h6 right i would ask
myself where is this knight going it's
probably going to g5
let's stop it from going to g5 not
necessary but clinical
now we can proceed with the development
of this bishop we could have also gone
g5 and fiance
that would have been possible yeah but
it it
okay there should be seven then we'll
bring a rook to d8 and step aside with
the king
so this is super straightforward play
that's why i'm playing fast
this is something that you get with
practice right technique and converting
advantages
of this kind something that just
involves
you practicing getting the intuition for
these kinds of positions
all right king c6 is also fine but
because we're up a piece
again we don't have to bring our king to
the center the sort of standard endgame
rules aren't as important
yeah so i i basically this the the
20 the original speed run we've sort of
ended
at a rating of about 23.70 which we were
going to go to 2500
but unfortunately i'm encountering a ton
of cheaters in the five-minute pool at
that level
so i feel like you know we've played
enough high level games to satisfy the
higher rated guys among you
but um this i think is what
will really help us round off this
notion of a speeder now we have more
time to talk about the game itself
during the game
and i'm not commenting on these moves
because i'm doing obvious stuff
and i'll answer after the game so
this will also all be on youtube all
right now we're just going to push this
pawn
and we're going to step aside at the
bishop now what would be the fastest
method of winning from this point on who
can propose a plan
obviously it's weird to talk about a
plan here we're up 100 pieces and pawns
but what can you guys suggest here
okay so we don't need to use our king
actually we don't need to use our king
all we need to do
is realize that this bishop and this
pawn aren't quite enough
to tackle the king bishop e3 he can go
king g3
but we can simply make another pass upon
google f5 g5 g4
and the two connected passers in
combination with the bishop
are enough material to force promotion
we don't need to use our king at all
g3 and watch what happens right now the
one thing you
don't want to do is play h2 which allows
the king to blockade the pawns himself
what we do want to do is do what we can
go either g2
or even slightly more precise to go
bishop e3 check
first then go g2 and g1 right
right g1 queen and the fastest mate is
to realize that this square
is the mating square we can prevent the
king from going any further and then
deliver checkmate on g3
white has plenty of pawn moves so
there's no stalemate
okay so
let's talk about the game and then we'll
end the stream
now in the black mirror diamer white
also sometimes goes f3 immediately
and life pro tip the best move for black
hair is to counter strike in the center
with e5
this is the refutation um
and the point is that if d takes e5 you
simply take the queen
and not only do you you know not only is
white now
uncastled but you can go knight c6
and you develop your knight quickly you
attack this pawn
white is in very big trouble here and
what you also have to realize folks
is that when people play a gambit gotta
play the psychology there
what are people who play gambit
generally looking for them generally
looking for sharp positions
positions with a lot of tactics and even
if you play the line that's not the best
but um but you play
a line that that gets into a type of
position they're not comfortable with
that could be worth its weight in gold
so just remember that when you're
deciding what line to play knight c3
knight f6 f3 is the right way to play
now bishop f5 looks like a great move
because
it simultaneously develops a piece
and defends the pawn on e4 but remember
something i said in the first game
one of the issues of developing your
pieces
without moving out any puns is that
these pieces can become susceptible to
pawns kind of
trampling all over them and there's a
nice kind of idea that white has here
which does exactly that it's similar to
what we did it's just on the other side
of the board it looks crazy but
it wins the e4 pawn what am i talking
about here
so use your imagination yeah g4
and g5 and the pawn is lost
so you might say well wait a second
isn't this extremely weakening well no
it's not that weakening and black is
still better here
but there's no reason to allow this
from that
[Music]
yeah knight takes e4 yeah we're not
talking about jordan peterson right now
i'm talking about the game
and does that make sense but so it's not
that weakening all right it's not that
weakening because white can still
develop his pieces in castle
all right
so knight c6 bishop f4
is a follow-up mistake so white should
play d5 and this is often the case we
sneak the knight into e5 establishing it
f takes e4 and one thing we can do here
is undermine white's pawn by playing e6
and i want you guys to notice
how white no longer has the f pawn which
means that black can bring the bishop
out to c5
and prevent white from castling short
because it covers the g1 square so this
position
is is one of those things that somebody
who would play the black redeemer might
not necessarily
want something that's kind of a
positional grind all right
so bishop f4 knight takes d4
and here at the very least
f takes e4 should have been preferred
okay but now we can get the bishop out
to g4
and black is up upon and dominating in
the center as well
so he exacerbated the problem by playing
knight b5 this allows the trait of
a lot of pieces and after bishop takes
b5 which he should have played
what would be a good approach for black
hair
and black has to be a little bit careful
because he is threatening to castle and
causes some
concrete problems so
how could we deal with that in one way
all right so we could play the move c6
bingo
good job and after castles we can play
either bishop d7 or we could simply go
king e8
talk the king away back to e8 and then
develop the bishop move the pawn out and
develop the other bishop
all right and we're up two pawns we're
in great shape here
i wouldn't say the game is over but for
a grand master
being down two puns in the end game
basically the game would be over thank
you corbin
all right so after he
blundered the knight or after he allowed
96 now the game really is over
everything else we do simple matter we
stop the knife from coming to g5
and that's basically it okay so
essentially we yeah we bring the rook in
we talk the king away
and uh we trade everything down the
defile and win the game it's very simple
very very simple give it to daniel well
i would never refuse it i appreciate it
all right
so any questions about this
um this game this was a pretty some
pretty straightforward conversion
i doesn't matter which rook to bring
behind the king at this point it's
purely academic all right at this point
it's just purely a matter of bringing
any rook yeah so
this is all very very straightforward
nothing really to write home about
okay so once again we go e4
and once again we're going to attempt
the danish gambit
i want you guys to see though how
amazing my positions
are in this opening because partly
because nobody
has actually taken the pawn okay so
knight to f6
that is a move we haven't seen before
and the issue with this move is much the
same i
actually don't i don't think it's a bad
move but i think the issue with it
is much the same as the issue with sort
of knight c6 which is that he's
he's developing his pieces but those
pieces are going to get trampled on
by my pieces and pawns because they're
not established
so we take the pawn on e5 and now this
knight on e4 again it looks intimidating
it's centralized
but it's it can be attacked in a variety
of different ways
so notice that black
wants to support the knight by playing
d7 to d5 so a move like bishop d3
or a move like queen e2 would allow d5
but actually oh but no queen e2 would
not allow d5 queen e2 is a really
interesting move so
bishop c4 i really really like because
bishop c4
um prevents him from playing d5 and
aims at the f71 and it threatens queen
d5 which i probably in my own game
i would play the move queen d5 here
attacking the knight
but i want to be a little bit more
flexible and i think unless he reacts
very precisely bishop c4 is going to be
an absolute crusher
does this make i hope this makes sense
yeah exactly drunk chess
so now he has to deal with okay so c6 is
a good move
um that's a very good move actually he
prepares d5 and he prevents me from
going
queen d5 kudos to my opponent so let's
see
now we have a couple ways to play this
position
let me think about this for a second
okay now
attacking this knight with queen e2 is a
really good idea now a lot of you guys
are saying wait a second this is a fork
but after queen f3 d5
he defends the knight and if we take on
passat
in that position then the knight returns
to take the pawn on d6 attacking the
bishop
and defending the f7 pawn so the end of
the day we haven't really gained
anything
i feel like this pawn on e5 is kind of
valuable i don't really want to trade it
because it's clamping down on black's
position so instead
we will go with queen e2 you guys might
say well wait wait a second how does
this stop d5
who can explain that to me and perhaps
he will even play d5 i don't think so i
think we'll go knight c5
but what happens after d5 how is this
different from queen f3
excellent uh on poisson is a pin
it pins the knife that's the point now
queen e2
also create i don't permanently stops d5
or d6
but let's develop our pieces quickly
maybe some of you are attracted by a
move like b4 again there's no need
to attack this knight that actually
weakens the queen side for no good
reason
instead we can decide now on which side
we want to castle on this is a good
opportunity to practice this kind of
decision making
because let's think about what we gain
from uh both castles now one thing that
you should realize is that in the long
run
okay stopping the motion of the d-pawn
is going to be a really good thing it's
going to make it very hard for black to
actually develop this bishop
and from that perspective which way
would you guys think is going to a
castle
yeah castling long takes one move longer
but we want to develop these pieces
anyways that's not really an argument
yeah queen side because that rook
is going to prevent the motion of the
d-pod it's going to actuate the queen in
addition
it's pretty reasonable to assume that
we're going to probably
attack on the king side and castling
queenside never hurts for that purpose
okay um knight c3
now here's another okay so he's gone d5
he sort of lost his patience and allowed
him so actually
he might have found a nice move here
because he might want to win this pawn
back although we're going to try to stop
him from doing that
okay well he's going to win it back but
it's going to come at great price king
d7 is a little bit extreme
now our thinking
does not or our um course of action
doesn't really change
we can develop this bishop to what
square
and actually this is a little bit of a
tricky moment
now i think almost all of you want to
play bishop f4
but the funny thing is after bishop f4
he has the nasty move queen to e8
offering the queen trade and we
certainly don't want to trade queens
here that's really going to hold us back
so instead of clinging to the spawn
let's let him take it
because by letting him take it now the
defile is going to be the
sort of main avenue of attack so we
actually
want him to take that one and this move
attacks the knight so it does everything
and and i mean this you should never be
afraid to give up a pawn like that
when you can sense that that his king is
in such danger
don't worry about clinging to a pawn
always try to have your priorities in
order in any position any given position
so bishop f7 yeah so now we castle
and now we're threatening to take the
knight on c5 there's very little like he
can move the knight
but then we're going to do something
down that d-file
yeah so
not really forcing okay so king king e8
obviously he also walks into a discovery
you can also play bishop g5 straight the
clinical move i suppose is bishop g5
check and actually yeah let's play
bishop g5 check because that wins the
queen
notice how i'm always looking for the
best move
um i'm not a lot of people would
automatically take
on c5 right but i'm taking a moment and
asking myself okay i have a discover
check
when you have a discovery check you've
got to look at all of the possible
discover checks because you might find
something that's
even more convincing than yeah and this
causes resignation
so yeah the danish has been has been
incredibly um incredibly successful thus
far people really struggle with it
i would say below six even at a 17 1800
level as
i'm sure we'll see all right
so quick look at this game yeah knight
f6 the e94
bishop c4 now what should he have done
here
i don't know i think that black is
already in very big trouble
it may be now just one thing
if instead we go bishop c5 um can
white play queen to d5 yeah it's really
fun opening can white play queen to d5
bruce mafia thank you so much i
appreciate it
so i think the jury is is out on this
the answer is yes because
after bishop f2 check you're not afraid
of this look at how black's pieces are
all hanging and mate is threatened black
is going to lose a piece
so this is a mentality that's super
important this mentality
of not having knee-jerk reactions to
your opponent's moves
a lot of us would look at this move and
say well wait a second this threatens f2
i need to defend that
moves like knight h3 or bishop e3 is
something i would see at a beginner
level
but even if you are a beginner you can
make a conscious effort
to put to see the bigger picture to put
your opponent's moves
in greater context and to understand
whether his threats are truly dangerous
and whether you can't make ests equal or
stronger threats
right well with time pressure nobody can
really manage that c6 queen e2
once again if queen f3 then d5 on
poisson and knight takes d6 black is
completely fine here
yeah bishop bishop bishop f7 is okay but
it only wins upon
bishop f7 is okay but at the end of the
day it only wins the pawn and queen d5
wins a piece
so it's flashy but queen e5 is better
all right so knight c5 knight c3 d5
on poisson he should have covered with
his bishop now here
yeah again i probably we would have
played bishop e3 and then castle
with an overwhelming initiative
and king d7 bishop e3 bishop dcx castles
actually no matter what he would have
done if he would have played knight e6
what would have been white's most
clinical move here what there's a move
that ends the game
immediately here and again trying to
think optimistically what question do
you want to ask yourself here well
you look at this position you say wait a
second i've got this huge pin
it stems naturally from the spin that
you should try to put pressure on the
bishop
look around the war what pieces could
attack that bishop well can we go bishop
f4 no there's a knight there
we can go knight e4 and that attacks the
bishop wins the bishop
and wins the game okay that move ends
the game immediately bishop c5 is
the right principle but again it blends
the bishop right this knight on e6
have to make sure you're seeing what
squares is controlling
okay fantastic guys so i hope you
enjoyed the game hope you enjoyed these
games we are up to 9
24 on the speedrun second speedrun
um and once we reach thousand eleven
hundreds the games
the games will be slightly longer
but yeah i hope you guys are enjoying
the second edition i hope i'm delivering
on my promise to
try to keep things as instructive as the
first speed run
you know even though i know i'm not
trying to you know sort of
live in the former glory of the first
speed and hopefully we're tackling some
new themes and
we'll continue to do that as i um
as i climb through the ranks thank you i
really
appreciate everybody's support every sub
every
um every member of the community is very
valued so
i think it's time to pause
thanks again everybody have a great rest
of the day
take care bye